découvrez maintenant l'histoire de jean
jean avec une histoire incroyable celle
d'un crime passionnel tout c'est un
reportage de nathan henneton c'est dans
cette petite cuisine des yvelines que
jean mas lourd est entré le 24 janvier
2004 gens rentrent dans sa cuisine il a
faim c'est l'heure du goûter c'est sûr
il ouvre son placard il voit le paquet
biskri est là
un biscuit dont jean malhoure avait
selon ses mots une petite fringale
mais tout ne s'est pas passé comme prévu
comment un de ces biscuits at il pu
s'échapper du pack est évident que
nathalie en plastique à l'intérieur du
paquet était à l'envers
qu'en est-il par exemple de cette usine
parce qu'il ya un flou médiatique nous
nous sommes rendus dans l'usiné qui
produit ces fameux biscuits fourrés au
chocolat pour tenter d'y voir plus clair
qu'à ce monsieur vous doji les questions
à vous poser sur le vice-président
répondre au savoir sont classifiés vous
plusieurs autres
je n'étais pas présent ce jour là donc
forcément je n'ai pas bien vu j'habite
dans un autre pays
je ne comprends pas ce que vous dites
oui monsieur est ce que vous pouvez
répondre clairement à ma question le
paquet était il retourne et oui ou non
notre interlocuteur reste muet la
barquette et elles viennent à l'envers
impossible d'en savoir plus vous savez
ce genre d'accident peut arriver à vous
et moi j'en malhoure est quelqu'un de
normal nos experts scientifiques ont
tenté de recréer les circonstances du
drame
mais leurs analyses n'ont rien donné de
concluant
cui à biscuits alors qu est il
réellement arrivé à ce biscuit
la question reste grande ouverte cet
événement sans précédent a tant marqué
les esprits qu'il a même inspiré un long
métrage dont voici les premières images
exclusives
la rencontre avec jean mas lourd a été
déterminant pour moi et quand il m'a
raconté son histoire et surtout comment
il s'en est sorti
combien d'hommes en sont capables après
plusieurs appels téléphoniques et l'aide
précieuse de nos témoins nous avons
enfin pu contacter l'homme au coeur de
cette affaire
jean mas lourd il s'est livré à nos
caméras pour nous raconter son histoire
sa confession et poignante mais je les
ramasse et de les manger
j'ai soufflé dessus et je les manger
quoi ils avaient le même ou un reportage
édifiant
on a tous vu la dure porte
à dessein